l'amélioration des temps la volonté de
gagner ou plutôt de ne pas perdre non
seulement dans le cyclisme et dans
presque toutes les disciplines sportives
entraîné une surenchère inadmissible la
preuve la voici le chemin de croix du
malheureux simpson je pense que c'est là
dans ce virage à la sortie de ce virage
que le 13 juillet 1967
tom simpson trouvait la mort sur les
pentes du ventoux oui c'est ici même
dans une atmosphère étouffante à deux
kilomètres du sommet un homme izac sur
la route
ce coureur c'est l'anglais tom simpson
les envoyés spéciaux de panoramas
maurice eveno jean louis normand sont là
pour vous présenter ce document
exceptionnel respiration artificielle
masque à oxygène
les techniques de réanimation sont
impuissants simpson est toujours dans un
état comateux état qui nécessite une
rapide évaluation sur le centre
hospitalier d'avignon à 17h40
les médecins ont constaté le décès de
tom simpson et refusé le permis
d'inhumer
voilà et nous en venons
au tour de france qui je vous le disais
en début de ce journal a été gagnée
comme prévu par laurent fignon
alors que l'étape du jour la dernière a
été remportée par le suisse gilbert glos
on a eu un peu peur cet après-midi sur
les pavés des champs elysées qu'elle
était mouillée ce qui a donné plusieurs
chutes spectaculaires mais la hiérarchie
établie après l'étape contre la montre
de dijon n'a en rien été bousculé et la
foule énorme qui a suivi à paris
l'arrivée du tour n'a pas été déçu celui
qu'elle attendait était au rendez-vous
et celui là c'était bien
laurent laurent fignon
c'était un beau tour de france très
chaud ça vous a rappellé souvenir oui
mon premier tour de france par un en
ligue 2 n'a vraiment rien
qui s'est finie en
pour moi c'est un grand champion il
mesure combien je sais quoi vous avez
qui a gagné tour date et non c'est
hinault qui a gagné tout il va gagner le
pot il va gagner tout le monde est-ce
qu'il a eu du mal à gagner le tour
oh non pas tellement
est ce que vous connaissez laurent
fignon
bon c'est à dire et c'est à dire bon
j'ai c'est à dire même pas ce que c'est
qu'un vélo
dites moi madame bovary alors enfin
l'arrivée de cette dernière étape du
tour de france
alors monsieur vous avez suivi sur le
france ah oui je suis de l'amendé vous
avez suivi le tour de france le
rouennais dit toi voir qu'est ce que
vous pensez du tour de france 82 c'est
sûr vous trouvez que ça a été un joli
ton enfant jouer jusqu'à gagner cette
région comme en région prison n'ont pas
fillon fignon chignon ça s'écrit f
ign au n fignon c'est le nouveau
champion d'un nouveau tour le dernier
mais de loin le plus rétro et le plus
passionnant de ces dix dernières années
et quand un maillot jaune arrive sur les
champs-elysées que craint-il sinon une
chute et pour ce maillot jaune l'anxiété
est encore plus grande lorsque une
averse tombe sur les pavés poussiéreux
et quand l'averse tombe les coureurs
aussi c'est presque fatal et iops
hotmail en sait quelque chose
m
au fait où et fignon on a vu wind and
mais le voilà fignon et c'est bon signe
on l'a cherché avec inquiétude ce
coureur dont les cheveux sont de la même
couleur que le maillot le voilà
rassurant non
et puis c'est le dernier tour et puis
c'est formidable formidable parce que
pascal jules démarre jules qu'on appelle
déjà julo imaginer une victoire de julo
le copain de fignon sur les champs
elysées pour une apothéose se serait tu
n'as poté mais jules et rejoint et
arrive le dernier passage sur la place
de la concorde in our à gagner sur les
champs elysées l'an passé laurent fignon
pense qu'il n'y a aucune raison pour ne
pas faire de même
il démarre
il démarre mais kelly a pris sa roue
suivi par le suisse glaus
et puis comme d'habitude c'est le sprint
sur les champs elysées
et kelly qui tente de remonter glaus
mais klaus qui passe d'un boyau
glaus va donc kelly mais fini on passe à
22 ans il est avec felice gimondi le
plus jeune vainqueur du tour de france
de l'après guerre
il portait le dossard numéro 15 c'est
celui de la voiture de prost fignon
prost ça ne vous dit rien
2e tour de france cycliste celui là avec
une étape beaucoup plus calme que celle
de la veille à fleurance et l'ancien
champion de france régis clair il l'a
emporté au sprint le français pascal
simon conserve le maillot jaune et
pourtant il est tombé dans des
conditions que certains ont jugé douteux
suffisamment en tout cas pour relancer
la polémique sur la loi du milieu dans
le peloton il ya ce soir une omoplate
fracturée
d'autant qu'un peu plus tard on
apprenait que job douteux mais lequel
jean françois rodriguez s'était dopé
lors des premières étapes du tour outre
une amende il risque un déclassement à
la dernière place des étapes incriminés
et 10 minutes de pénalisation au
classement général alain vernon un drame
a marqué l'étape d'aujourd'hui donc ont
annoncé comme une étape de transition
après la douloureuse traversée des
pyrénées c'est christian jourdan qui se
relève ici mais la chute du kilomètre 46
a surtout fait une victime de marque
puisque pascal simon a bien failli
monter dans l'ambulance
pourtant la loi du tour dicte toujours
ces conditions et tandis que simon
repartez endolori régis clair le
champion france 82 remporté au sprint la
11e étape à fleurance de longs jours
dans bien revenu et le lente et freaks
pirard le vainqueur de créteil
c'est phil anderson qui règle le sprint
du peloton avec deux minutes et 3
secondes de retard tandis que hotmail qu
on l'apprend convaincu de dopage
rétrograde à la 25e place avec plus de
16 minutes de retard quant à simon il ne
décolère pas
avec un homme blessé je pense de poids
normal après sa première un ex idowu un
attentat je vous entendu critiquer
violemment un des adversaires ont besoin
oui parce que quand tu vas bosser rezé
il a l'image ici un quelques a fait
tomber maintenant c'est de mon enquête
je vais pas je veux pratiquer un
gouverneur et le sud s'il en est
coresponsable mais s'il en est
responsable doit être pire non c'est pas
l'excision de courtételle a des
conséquences dans le lot parce que puis
je vaux est bousculé en temps en ce
moment là on fera de la corruption et je
trouve ça tout à fait normal et ce sont
envoyés pour moi c'est vraiment affreux
qui va faire ses bourreaux qui est tombé
parce qu'il a touché la roue a gardé
puis moi j'étais dans les environs s'est
pas je ne savais même pas que simon est
tombé quand on achète ses produits mais
c'est la guerre donc le taux annoncé par
qu'agostino partie et ils ont commencé à
rouler moi je me suis mis avec qui
roulait et puis bourreau a touché la
roue à son équipier puis pourrait tomber
et yvon est tombé d'enfants
vous plaidez vous coupable à du tout en
réalité pascal simon souffre ce soir
d'une fracture de l'omoplate dos il
devra conserver son bras immobilisé
durant près d'un mois
j'ai peur car j'ai senti un craquement
dans mon épaule est bien la remontée de
mourhino j'étais sous des lois mais chez
les sujets proposés déjà j'ai porté ce
besoin à la fin du tour de france
jardiner que des pâtes et je dois dire
un grand merci à toute l'équipe de
jouets qui font de même
en avoir ramené ses à florence et
maintenant à moins d'avoir beaucoup de
courage pour essayer fini très pauvre en
soufre
le reportage de patrick naf est prêt un
reportage sur la chute spectaculaire de
bernard hinault et sur l'état du
cycliste patrick bernard hinault blessés
à l'arrivée de la 14e étape
autrans saint-etienne diagnostic double
fracture des os propres du nez et
entaille au cuir chevelu
tous ces produits dans les 300 derniers
mètres lors du sprint du peloton
inovallée anderson whitney est âgé de
rennes s'accroche c'est la chute
une chute dont la cause reste
mystérieuse
l'autre victime de cette 14e étape c'est
le vainqueur le colombien luis herrera
qui tombe dans une descente à quelques
kilomètres de l'arrivée plaît à la
pommette et au front mais rien de grave
parti seul au 117e km le colombien a
franchi la ligne d'arrivée avec 47
secondes d'avancé sur ses adversaires
c'est sa deuxième victoire d'étape
derrière seul esprit pour la seconde
place un sprint remporté par le belge
ludo peters devant le lieutenant de
bernard hinault l'américain greg lemond
et ben et robert forest
le gros du peloton arrivera deux minutes
plus tard et comme le veut le règlement
les coureurs qui ont chuté dans le
dernier kilomètre sont crédités du même
temps pour ino de crossfire mais pas
trop de mal
tout le monde y à rien si je suis né
casse et 2.266 deux points de la tête
m brasse mais des genres mais devra
alors je pense que c'est le plus
important que c'est parce que dans le
sprint
il emmenait le sprint je crois que c'est
madiot qui a dû elle va essayer d'aller
et moi j'ai pu chanter pour aller dans
les sprints avec avec steve est un
coureur qui arrivait sur le côté kamel
est ce que c'est le foot d'anderson j'ai
pas vu le film je crois qu'il faut voir
le film pour savoir si c'est de sa faute
si c'est pas de sa faute alors qu'il ya
eu comme ça jouer sur le côté de la tête
aussi rien ça c'est rien deux poêles
marque de fabrique ici le nez cassé et
autres il n'y a rien du tout on pouvait
au classement général hinault conserve
le maillot jaune et greg lemond valises
une bonne opération en reprenant plus
d'une minute à stephen roche et sean
kelly 5e steve bauer
on passe au cyclisme tour de france est
12ème étape aujourd'hui 12 juillet c'est
normal entrepris de la gaillarde et
bordeaux victoire d'un américain au
sprint à boire debout
oui australie qui sait comment il va au
filet gagnant gagnant très français
garde le maillot jaune marcia lins le
gagnant voilà ce qu'on retiendra surtout
que c'est dès aujourd'hui bien c'est la
chute et l'abandon de sean kelly qui
était l'un des favoris
pierre pradinas 50e kilomètre le peloton
et près de sarlat un attroupement du
mouvement un homme le dr portes seront
sur le lieu du drame
vous l'avez reconnu jeunes qu'elle y en
est la victime courageux irlandais
remonte sur son vélo
aidé par ses coéquipiers et au prix d'un
fantastique et fort le favori du tour
repart par pour longtemps
malheureusement 20 km 20 km d'horreur
c'en est trop la douleur l'emportent
kelly le maudit s'arrête
diagnostic fracture de la clavicule
après le tour d'espagne et paris roubaix
le tour de france
c'en est fini pour kelly l'histoire de
cette 12e étape retiendrons donc
l'abandon de kelly la victoire au sprint
david phinney et le maintien du maillot
jaune sur les épaules du français
martial gayant
au menu de demain les premiers cols de
montagne
madame monsieur bonsoir le tour de
france commence mal à l'arrivée à
armentières cet après midi c'est le
sprint final les coureurs se déporte sur
la droite de la route vers les barrières
de sécurité c'est la chute
plusieurs coureurs percute un policier
qui prenait une photo de coureurs ont
été sérieusement blessé le belge niels
haine et le français jalabert qui était
le meilleur français de ce tour le récit
complet des événements
thierry clopeau voici le vélo de laurent
jalabert ou tout du moins ce qu'il en
reste après le choc
à près de 70 km heure dix secondes plus
tôt
c'est le sprint
un policier imprudente et qu'elle est
par rapport à la barrière qui prend une
photo le landais nelly scène le frappe
alors de plein fouet
derrière ces jalabert qui heurte lui
aussi pleine phase l'agent des forces de
l'ordre est un panneau publicitaire
stupéfaction dans le public
les deux coureurs et le policier assez
sérieusement blessé sont immédiatement
secouru par les médecins du tour premier
diagnostic
le policier souffre d'un enfoncement du
thorax laurent jalabert ensemble à
plusieurs lésions à la mâchoire et des
fractures aux incisives quentin ellison
traumatisme crânien il est transporté
comme les deux autres à l'hôpital
d'armentières
puis sur le chu de lille pour examen au
scanner
mais d'ores et déjà les deux coureurs
sont déclarés inaptes à poursuivre le
tour
la question que tout le monde se pose ce
soir est ce une faute d'organisation ou
une erreur humaine 50 mètres de
l'arrivée la police qui a au milieu de
la route presque les photos de la
photographie sur la ligne d'arrivée
pour la direction du tour il y avait
bien eu faute du policier tentative
d'explication c'est donc une espèce de
d'erreur humaine de la part de sept
jaunes police on peut ne pas incriminer
totalement dans la mesure où ces agents
de police locaux que nous devons chaque
jour sont différents qu'ils ne
connaissent pas les usagers tour de
france les risques du tour de france
mais enfin n'oubliez pas que le peloton
traverse villes les villages à parfois
plus de 60 kilomètres heure les voitures
du tour à 100 km heure alors surtout
rester derrière les barrières c'est
votre sécurité et la sécurité des
coureurs qui en dépend il faut que ce
tour passe une fête
une casquette de cyclistes à celui que
l'on n'arrête plus laurent jalabert
vainqueur cet après-midi du critérium
international
après ses victoires dans paris-nice et
milan san remo laurent jalabert qui
savoure d'autant plus ses succès qu'il
revient de loin après son accident du
tour de france l'année dernière thierry
clopeau laurent jalabert a dû se croire
maudit à l'arrivée de la deuxième étape
ce matin
le coureur dnc a failli revivre une bien
mauvaise aventure une petite collision
avec un spectateur
heureusement sans gravité malgré cet
incident de parcours cela ne l'a pas
empêché de remporter cet après-midi le
critérium international
jalabert en jaune c'est toute la france
du vélo qui se met à rêver une image
entretenir jusqu'au mois de juillet
jusqu'au tour de france une fois le
classique d'avril terminer mon principal
objectif sera le tour de france est
alors à ce moment là tout ce que je vais
faire ce soir en fonction du tour donc à
ce moment là je commence à y penser
pourtant laurent jalabert revient de
loin le 3 juillet dernier à armentières
il percute un policier dans le sprint
final
la chute est terrible violence et les
dégâts pour jalabert sont considérables
cage thoracique enfoncée
plusieurs fractures de la mâchoire et
des bleus un peu partout sur son lit
d'hôpital jalabert souffre mais ne doute
pas c'est une partie de ma vie et
laurent jalabert à force de courage va
se donner les moyens de cette ambition
il ya trois semaines c'était paris nice
la première grande course par étapes de
la saison
la première victoire du revenant plus
fort encore une semaine plus tard il
remporte sa première grande classique
milan san remo devant l'italien
fondriest jalabert rejoint l'or est plus
grand
sa victoire aujourd'hui au critérium
international de la route est carrément
à un exploit historique jamais un
coureur n'avait remporté ses trois
courses d'affilée
bien sûr on commence à penser très fort
au tour de france le tour qui lui a valu
tant de souffrance mais qui n'a pas fait
lui porter malheur en 80 que vous avez
une victoire d'étape en prime jalabert
avait endossé sur les champs-elysées le
maillot vert du classement par points
avec de nouvelles qualités de grimpeur
qu'on ne soupçonnait pas il peut
désormais rêver d'un maillot d'une autre
couleur le jaune il a si bien
mais le tour de france a débuté dans le
drame il hier soir avec la chute de
chris boardman le britannique champion
du monde du contre la montre
chris boardman a tout tenté dans le
prologue à saint brieuc sous la pluie à
la nuit tombée mais il a chuté au bout
d'une minute trente de course
il souffre d'une double fracture à la
cheville gauche et au bras droit thierry
clopeau et alain poirier l'on
rencontrait sur son lit d'hôpital avant
qu'il ne reparte pour manchester
je prends quelques points mais je trouve
plus et voilà dix ans j'ai connu je suis
à 50 du cirque matériel franchissement
donc répond c'est possible pour gagner
des prologues ainsi que pamela prologue
au jeu trop ambitieux pour les dix ans
si elle passe tout le plus mauvais
virage n'a pas en face ils sont maîtres
c'est fini je suis troy dessus ça se
passe quasiment premier un petit métier
pour fait la grande cros et trois
semaines avec l'escroc
voilà c'est première opportunité pour
repenser malgré un sou préventive et on
s'était su mais ce concert à la future
le docteur m'a dit ceci si ce même de
moi ce que j'ai cassé les deux
après moi je penses tu te fixes c'est
possible pour l'achat musiques du monde
donc j'essaie pour le championnat mais
souvient il albert la dernière il avait
nettement chuté après j'espère c'est là
même la merci crise
cette étape la plus attendue a donc
commencé dans le drame je lisais avec ce
matin la chute mortelle de fabio
casartelli 25 ans champion olympique à
barcelone récit laurent frédéric bollée
immobile est pratiquement déjà sans vie
fabio casartelli j ai même le sol dans
une mare de sang
à ses côtés d'autres coureurs impliqués
dans une chute terrible on est au 34e km
de la 15e étape du tour de france
au détour d'un virage de la descente du
portet d'aspet le drame a frappé
manifestement l'italien a heurté une des
bornes en béton qui longe la route le
choc le plonge alors immédiatement dans
un coma profond
difficile de savoir ce qui s'est
vraiment passé
eca crevaison fautes en tout cas sans
casque sous la chaleur aujourd'hui
casartelli ne se relèvera pas il avait
fêté son 25e anniversaire
il y a deux jours les secours pourtant
sont arrivés très vite
soigné sur place puis évacuée par
hélicoptère casartelli sur un victime de
trois arrêts cardiaques pendant son
transfert le décès sera prononcée
officiellement à 14 heures également
touchés dans l'accident l'allemand
baldinger et l'italien périgny souffrent
de traumatismes divers
quant aux français de reins' il a plongé
dans le ravin et s'est blessé gravement
à la cuisse gauche
professionnelle depuis deux ans
casartelli le premier coureur à décéder
sur le tour depuis tony simpson en 67
on se souviendra de lui comme le
champion olympique en titre de la
spécialité en 92 à barcelone il avait
triomphé et avait offert à tous les
observateurs un visage rayonnant à
l'image de sa jeunesse pleine de la bim
au tour de france et le suisse alex
houleux qui portait le maillot jaune ce
matin au départ de la première étape le
suisse en effet remporté hier le
prologue battant de deux petites
secondes le britannique chris boardman
qui l'an dernier avait été victime d'une
grave chute lors précisément du prologue
à saint brieuc loyer alors sous l'orage
cleeren juillet 1993 dans le tgv qui
l'emmène à paris pour la dernière étape
du tour les gars ligne rennes découvre
dans la presse l'exploit de chris
boardman qui vient de battre le record
de l'heure un exploit qui n'a pas
échappé à l'équipe gan qui s'adjuge des
services de l'anglais le 2 juillet 94
chris boardman prend donc le départ de
son premier tour de france et quel
départ il remporte le prologue en
établissant un record de vitesse encore
inégalé à ce jour mais il abandonne le
peloton au bout de deux semaines le 1er
juillet 95 boardman repart en trombe
sous leur âge de saint brieuc mais son
prologue la ruine durera que 3 km un
mauvais virage une terrible chute de
fracture birdman rentrer à la maison
en vacances dans la terre avec ma
famille la première fois dans le train
je reste à la maison dans la tête c'est
si c'est bon parce que j'ai le temps
pour 36 me plaît aux pour penser à pour
le 'future' passé c'est un bon expert
hier goldman n'était pourtant pas très
rassuré lorsqu'il a pris le départ
difficile en effet de chasser les
mauvais souvenirs lorsqu'on doit à
nouveau affronter une route mouillée des
virages serrés mais cette année il a
décidé de terminer le tour alors il a
opté pour la prudence
ce qui n'a pas empêché de se classer
deuxième de ce prologue à deux petites
secondes du suisse alex joue le même
lorsqu'il ne crois pas de risque chris
boardman reste vraiment un superman du
pronom
le russe berline s'empare du maillot
jaune à l'issue d'une première étape de
montagne épique entre chambéry et les
arcs luc leblanc est le héros du jour il
sera en direct avec tous dans ce journal
les vacances débutent sous la pluie et
le froid inquiétude à la sncf après
l'incarcération de loïk le floch prigent
et les témoignages accablants pour
mladic et karadzic au tribunal
international de la haye madame monsieur
bonsoir le tour de france a connu l'une
de ces étapes les plus folles entre
chambéry et les arcs un cocktail
détonnant de pluie de vente de nuages et
de cols à franchir
au fil des kilomètres on assister au
décrochage de jalabert à l'abandon du
maillot jaune à des chutes
spectaculaires et à la défaillance digne
du rennes ce soir le russe berline et
maillot jaune après cette étape
remportée de quelle façon par luc
leblanc récit d'une journée un peu folle
clair et nous on l'imaginé en jaune mais
il a vécu une journée noire laurent
jalabert lâché dès les premiers
kilomètres de cette première étape de
montagne dans l'ascension du col de la
madeleine
laurent jalabert qui malgré l'aide de
ses coéquipiers ne parviendra jamais à
rejoindre le peloton et dans ce peloton
bien sûr il y à une dure elle joue le
holà nobert dinero giger bref tous les
favoris qui maintiennent une cadence
d'enfer
il y a bien sûr aussi des tentatives
d'échappées comme celle des ce quartier
ne vit rien quel blanc dont la montée du
cormet de roseland mais les deux
français n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
un jour comme celui là la solidarité
nationale ne joue pas la bagarre
heureusement sera de courte durée car il
faut rester concentré la route est
dangereuse et dans la descente vers
bourg-saint-maurice
johan bruyneel bascule dans le ravin une
chute heureusement sans gravité dans la
montée vers les arcs luc leblanc
effectué une extraordinaire remontée
l'ancien champion du monde s'impose avec
plus de 50 secondes d'avancé sur le
peloton
un peloton qui a distancé miguel
indurain le quintuple vainqueur du tour
de france est à son tour victime d'une
incroyable défaillance il coupera la
ligne avec plus de quatre minutes de
retard rétrogradant à la 14e place du
classement général
quant à laurent jalabert arrivée 13
minutes après luc leblanc il sait qu'il
a perdu toute chance de remporter le
tour de france
un bond de sport avec le tour de france
le maillot jaune change d'épaulés
revient à l'estonien car si [ __ ] c'est
le belge tom steels qui remporte cette
deuxième étape une étape plutôt
mouvementée nathanaël de rincquesen
l'hydroglisseur voilà bien le meilleur
moyen pour voir le peloton progressé
tout au long des quatre km du bois de
noirmoutier
le bois devait marquer les esprits il va
laisser des traces
une chute collective au milieu du
peloton entraîne un embouteillage la
chaussée est étroite
104 coureurs sont pris au piège fameux
quelques favoris joue le riz néogothique
brochard ils arriveront à saint nazaire
avec plus de 6 minutes de retard sur ce
groupe de soixante dix échappés bien
malgré eux sur la ligne d'arrivée tom
steels s'impose juste devant jan
kirsipuu kirsi pu très habile
aujourd'hui notamment lors des sprints
bonifications a repris 30 secondes à
lance armstrong bien plus qu'il n'en
fallait pour dépasser l'américain au
classement général et au pire à
l'estonie le premier maillot jaune de
son histoire
laurent jalabert est en direct avec nous
de lescar dans les pyrénées atlantiques
et laurent jalabert quelle étape 162 km
en solitaire s'y colle dans la journée
tout seul ce soir le maillot à pois du
meilleur grimpeur pour la première fois
de votre carrière et vous allez nous
faire croire vous n'êtes pas un
spécialiste de la montagne
oui si j'en étais un jour attendue
finale et j'aimerais si elle gagne au
sommet aujourd'hui mais bon c'est vrai
que je suis pas non plus minables en
montagne mais bon j'ai besoin si je veux
gagner de d'attaquer de loin comme ça
c'était bien tenté j'ai pris de gros
risques mais mais c'était ce prix là que
j'avais une chance de gagner aujourd'hui
alors gros risques on va revoir l'image
vous avez été victime d'une chute c'est
quoi une justement une trop grande prise
de risques dans la descente où
finalement une grande fatigue
normalement là précisément la descente
était terminée
c'était surtout la fatigue de l'agité
moins réussis dans la dernière des
simples j'ai fait une petite erreur de
freinage et j'ai trop bloquer les frères
l'avoir je suis parti la victoire
d'étape pour lance armstrong qui vous
rattrape in extremis caisse conso qu'est
ce qu'on ressent à ce moment là après
162 kilomètres seul c'est quoi c'est un
grand courant d'air qui passe ah oui
c'était courant des rails est passé vite
bon même s'il m'a fait signe à la terre
à 18 mois non je peux quand il m'aurait
fallu autre chose qu'un vélo pour
montrer avec lui mais bon c'est comme ça
c'est le destin
c'était difficile d'aller au bout mais
j'ai quand même fait une belle journée
sur une belle étape
je suis très très content de ma journée
alors public considérable dans les
pyrénées aujourd'hui on vous a vu à
certains moments manifester votre
énervement l'égard de certains kibaki
vous à rose qui vous pousse qui vous
tape même si c'est sympathique ça ça
énerve parfois non mais en règle
générale je suis resté très calme
aujourd'hui j'ai pas eu de problème avec
le public
bien au contraire aussi ce n'est
peut-être qu'une fois ou deux où on
arrose avec de l'eau trop froide et ça
surprend un petit peu mais mais bon rien
de bien oui c'est vrai que c'est une
popularité énorme pour vous on a vu
beaucoup de panneaux et affiches à votre
nom alors deux victoires d'étapes dont
celle du 14 juillet ce maillot du
meilleur grimpeur pour la première fois
on vous souhaite de conserver encore
demain soir quoi qu'il arrive ce tour
restera un grand cru pour vous oui tout
à fait c'est si ce n'est le meilleur ça
me tout meilleurs et bon quoi qu'il
arrive jusqu'à paris l'excellent c'est
clair mais bon je vais essayer encore de
faire quelque chose de bien ici à la fin
on vous le souhaite merci beaucoup
laurent jalabert vous étiez en direct
avec nous
aujourd'hui dans la plus éprouvante des
étapes pyrénéennes
lance armstrong s'est offert une très
sérieuse option sur une troisième
victoire consécutive dans le tour de
france l'américain désormais en jaune
l'a emporté au pla d'adet avec une
facilité toujours aussi déconcertante
une étape marquée par de nombreuses
chutes mais surtout une formidable
échappée en solitaire de laurent
jalabert 194km d'anthologie résumé par
nathanaël de rincquesen et alain poirier
sur la ligne de saint lary laurent
jalabert était bien le coureur le plus
attendu emporté dans la foule
le français a encore vécu une sacrée
journée 170 km d'échappée
seul face au peloton dans une étape aux
allures de montagnes russes
alors jalabert joue les équilibristes
dans les vertigineuse descente
pyrénéenne après 80 km heure pas le
temps de reprendre son souffle
voilà déjà la route qui s'élève une
nouvelle difficulté sur le terrain des
grimpeurs jalabert n'est pas là pour
faire de la figuration
il enchaîne l'école et les ascensions
plus dur les unes que les autres à 50
kilomètres de l'arrivée le français à
dix minutes d'avancé sur armstrong
derrière jalabert la bagarre éclate
jan ullrich tente le tout pour le tout
mais n'arrive pas à décrocher armstrong
l'allemand prend des risques un peu trop
dans la descente de peyresourde
il rate un virage
plus de peur que de mal oulrich remonte
en selle prêt à se lancer aux trousses
de l'américain inutile armstrong
l'attend quelques kilomètres plus bas
continuent à attaquer quand champions
toujours en tête de la course jalabert
est à son tour victime d'une chute au
pied de la dernière ascension mais le
français repart quelques mètres plus
tard sous vélo lui joue des tours
encore dix secondes de perdues à 10 km
de l'arrivée
comme pour lui ôter tout regret
armstrong dans les derniers lacets de la
montée vers saint lary démarre comme
d'habitude au nez et à la barbe d'une
riche jalabert est vite rejoint cette
fois il n'y a plus personne
sur le chemin de l'américain qui s'en va
remporter sa troisième victoire du tour
et enfilé son premier maillot jaune de
l'année certainement pas le dernier non
voilà monsieur bonsoir l'étape
s'annonçait décisive
elle l'a été réservant même l'un de ses
coups de théâtre qui participent à la
légende du tour dix kilomètres avant
l'arrivée jan ullrich très bien parti et
tous ri dans un virage alors qu'il
disposait d'une avance de deux secondes
sur son principal concurrent
lance armstrong l'américain a désormais
sa cinquième victoire à portée de roues
il a terminé l'épreuve troisième
il dispose désormais d'une avance d'une
minute 16 au classement général
l'épreuve contre la montre a été gagné
par l'écossais david millar qui avait
connu bien des déboires lors du prologue
compte rendu nathanaël de rincquesen la
dig picard un tour de france ça tient
parfois pas grand chose un virage mal
négocié et voilà les rêves de victoire
de jan ullrich qui s'envole juste
derrière même sam trombe lancé à pleine
vitesse ne laisse pas passer l'occasion
de reprendre quelques précieuses
secondes à son rival pour je repars sans
conviction il a perdu le tour quand
j'écoute chute
je vais être inquiet tranquille sans
doute c'est pas important pour pour le
tap un maillot jaune averti en vaut deux
armstrong gère son avance et ne prend
aucun risque
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
où le riche roule en éclaireur à plus de
54 km heure de moyenne
les deux hommes arrivent canon dessus
des trombes d'eau oulrich à sa tête des
mauvais jours
il est 4e de l'étape est plus que jamais
deuxième du tour
voilà juste ne pas toucher aux coudes
pour le lest et c'est dommage qu'il n'a
pas gagné d'étape à ce que
cet après midi sur la ligne d'arrivée
malgré la pluie et la fatigue
lance armstrong s'est laissé aller à
quelques signes extérieurs de bonheur
cette victoire
l'américain est tout de suite allé la
partager avec sa femme de m'asseoir
lance armstrong rejoindra anquetil
merckx hinault indurain dans la légende
du tour de france
la première étape du tour de france
après la cérémonie de départ à l'endroit
même où les premières équipes s'était
élancé il ya cent ans
place à la compétition la vraie avec une
série de chutes et la victoire de
l'italien alessandro pettachi natale de
luxe à la chute est spectaculaire
elle aurait pu être dramatique cet après
midi à 500 mètres de la ligne d'arrivée
à mot le peloton connaît sa première
chute collective du tout une quinzaine
de coureurs tombe par terre
créons un étonnant embouteillages les
premiers blessés comme ici jimmy casper
sont immédiatement prise en charge les
moins touchés passe la ligne un peu
comme ils peuvent
une certitude le tour commence mal on a
évité toute la journée comme en 1903 le
tour s'offre un départ au réveil matin
de montgeon compétitive cotillons
accompagnent les coureurs
le public est comblé c'est exceptionnel
c'est pour ça que je suis venu la
déplacer que j'ai pas devant la télé
la caravane les couleurs pour le plus
grand plaisir des spectateurs
la première échappée du centenaire et
française beneteau mangin et puis
quinger post compagnie au peloton
ils comptent jusqu'à huit minutes
d'avancé malheureusement pour eux les
espoirs de victoire s'envole un peu
avant l'arrivée lorsque les équipes de
sprinteurs accélère
ça peut faire mémoire un peloton lancé à
60 à l'heure dans les 15 derniers
kilomètres pas trop d'espoir sur la
ligne de mots l'italien alessandro
petacchi règle au sprint ce qu'il reste
du peloton
c'est sa première victoire sur le tour
de france bradley mcgee lui a toujours
le sourire
son aventure en jaune continue
france avec un maillot jaune qui
changent encore des pôles schumacher
victime d'une chute et détrôner ce soir
par le luxembourgeois kirschen et c'est
un jeune espoir italien
ricco qui remporte l'étape sur place
nathanaël de rincquesen régis mater
depuis le début du tour c'est presque
devenu une tradition chaque jour dès les
premiers kilomètres de l'étape des
coureurs français faussé compagnie au
peloton
cima chavanel benoît vaugrenard et
freddy bichot multiplie les efforts
pendant 180 km sur les routes du massif
central
les trois hommes doivent se battre
contre la route qui s'élève le soleil
qui tape le peloton qui revient et
l'appui qui glace ça fait beaucoup pour
des échappées la chaleur on a pris un
coup
aujourd'hui ce qui a permis de refroidir
un petit peu ça reste toujours des
journées difficiles parce qu'il n'y a
pas trop de votre plat c'est toujours en
prison tout le monde connaît le massif
central s'est hissé dans le peloton la
tension est palpable
cadel evans s'énerve contre un gendarme
qui a failli faire tomber
chavanel lui arrête les frais à 15
kilomètres de l'arrivée il a récupéré le
maillot de meilleur grimpeur
l'échappée terminée débute alors une
nouvelle course riche en intensité en
rebondissements à 300 mètres de la ligne
stefan schumacher le maillot jaune
heurte la route d'un concurrent
il perd l'équilibré 32 secondes et sa
précieuse tunique pour cette première
arrivée au sommet valverde et evans sont
roue dans roue mais c'est ricardo ricco
l'italien qui s'imposent
les transalpins voient en lui le futur
pantani et en italie c'est un compliment
sur le podium
kim kirchen a sorti son plus beau
sourire depuis charlie gaulle il ya 50
ans aucun luxembourgeois n'avait porté
le maillot jaune
une rencontre
un dimanche de sport maintenant avec
d'abord la première étape du tour en
ligne après le prologue hier les
coureurs ont pris la direction de
bruxelles une étape de plat de
nombreuses chutes et un sprint remporté
par l'italien petacchi 36 ans et toutes
ses jambes apparemment julien benedetto
et david d'ahmed à mèze petit village
belge en effervescence pour le passage
de la grande boucle
c'est ici qu'habitent le cannibale eddy
merckx quintuple vainqueur du tour
possède une usine de cycles juste à côté
mais c'est une terre de vélo
ici wallons et flamands sont d'accord
sur un point
merckx est un héros de plus jean le plus
grand chose de nous maintenant le
gardien encore à mèze on n'a pas perdu
une miette de la rocambolesque première
étape marquée par une succession de
chutes c'est d'abord un chien qui
flanquent à terre une partie du peloton
dans le dernier kilomètre le maillot
jaune fabian cancellara chute à son tour
après un autre accrochage l'italien
petacchi 36 ans remporte l'étape à
bruxelles distancé cancellara conserve
le maillot jaune grâce au règlement
quand un coureur chute dans le dernier
kilomètre il est classé dans le même
temps que le vainqueur
c'est vraiment nerveux et à la fin
c'était la folie cancellara reste donc
le patron du sourd mais sur le podium
eddy merckx
lui a un peu volé la vedette
le tour de france maintenant avec une
journée un peu folle sur les pavés du
nord
armstrong qui perd du temps chavanel qui
perd son maillot jaune et cancellara qui
redevient le patron a longtemps dit
mathieu ivanovski épique dantesque dans
la poussière des pavés du nord les
coureurs du tour ou là un train d'enfer
13 kilomètres de souffrance
j'en peux plus ils ont vraiment ils vont
vraiment au goût du ski de ce qu'ils
font chapeau bas respect je le ferai pas
cet après midi le grand ménage a bien eu
lieu
plusieurs chutes dont celle de frank
schleck l'un des favoris du tour
la clavicule cassée le champion du
luxembourg abandonne jours de galère
pour le maillot jaune sylvain chavanel
crève deux fois satané pavé le français
en jette son vélo dans le fossé
ce soir chavanel n'est plus en tête de
ce tour ennuis mécaniques plus de
crevaisons par dessus ça m'a pas
avantagé ça c'est sûr elle lance
armstrong dans la tourmente
également victime d'une crevaison
l'américain se bat seul et perd à
l'arrivée 55 secondes sur contador
l'espagnol incapable de suivre le rythme
des meilleurs dans les derniers
kilomètres et aremberg c'est le
norvégien hushovd qui s'imposent
mais la bonne affaire est pour andy
schleck le luxembourgeois reprend de
précieuses secondes sur ses rivaux pour
moi mais c'est un jeu perdu mon frère
aujourd'hui et une journée seulement
après l'avoir cédé le suisse cancellara
récupère son maillot jaune
cette étape aura tenu toutes ses
promesses